make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob
and we are picking back up again with
avengers and new avengers and this one
this video is going to be a horse right
this is going to be a chunky video
um so what we end up doing here is we
initially pick up
with basically the necropolis right the
city of the dead
in wakanda and we basically pick up with
the arrival of two individuals now we
don't immediately find out who they are
instead we switch over to the black swan
and the black swan is kind of going on
with this little bit of a
like a speech of sorts right this kind
of monologue right talking about the
nature of patience that the only way
that she was able to endure her
captivity when the illuminati was
holding her in the basement of or really
in the necropolis itself
was to basically humble herself right to
accept the fact that that's where she
was that she was basically a person who
was being held captive
in doing that she would basically allow
herself to basically cope with it as
best she could
that's really all it was for her to just
maintain the patient she needed to wait
for the time to come
when she could basically escape and one
of the things she says here is that the
only way to really become patient like
that is to humble yourself right to
overcome the natural desire
to fight or fly but that can only really
be accomplished
if you are willing to take the needs of
others and put them before yourself
right it's the only real way to be able
to humble yourself and that's when she
basically tells tony stark
you'll never make it in this place
because who have you ever served besides
yourself and what this does is it
explains
why tony stark is here now this is kind
of an important thing it's an easy thing
to kind of throw away but it's very
important if you were following marvel
comics at the time especially iron man
and the reason why was because we got
some cool iron man stories right uh
kieran gillen's iron man run
but what we also ended up getting was a
story called superior iron man and
that's where that armor comes from the
armor that's all kind of broken and
screwed up that comes that's the
superior iron man suit right the endo
sim suit and what we ended up finding
out was that at the end of superior
iron man tony stark just took off and
then we didn't hear from him again right
we didn't get anything out of iron man
until we basically got to the end of
jonathan hickman's avengers new avengers
until we get to this point right till we
get well this is near the end but until
we get to this point this is the next
time that we see him and one of the
questions a lot of people had is what
happened
right what happened between the ending
of superior iron man and this moment
right here and we basically get this
kind of explanation
that comes directly from uh from black
swan herself and it really kind of comes
in the way of like tony stark
basically tormenting her right where she
we're not really tormenting her but kind
of giving her a hard time where she
starts to talk about despair and how
despair will basically lead star to a
place that he doesn't want to be in
right the tony stark is basically here
he's in a place he doesn't want to be at
and that despair
will more or less take hold that given
time it'll seize control of everything
and basically it'll turn his entire life
upside down and then he kind of comments
and he says like day after day
week after week i've been here for
months right i've been in this place for
months basically the last eight months
right so
superior iron man dead ends to the
beginning of the time runs out story but
he's like i've been here for months and
months and months and months and you
keep showing up here and you keep
talking to me do you want to know why i
think it is that you keep showing up
here and talking to me and she asks why
and he says because i think you're in
love and this is where tony stark fails
this is the failure of tony stark right
here in this situation that he's in tony
stark is stuck here and there's a reason
why he's here and it doesn't necessarily
have to do with the direct reason why he
got here we'll actually find out what
this reason is here in a little while
but it's tony stark playing coy then you
just can't really take things seriously
you know he's like don't be offended
right i mean you know like you're in a
situation where basically you're bound
by ever reducing options your choices
are getting less and less and because
your choices are getting less and less
i'm looking better and better now if i'm
being honest with you guys that's a
terrible reason to love someone
right but the idea behind this is that
when it when it comes to tony stark
he can't take this seriously he's just
kind of goofing off and that's and
that's
when he's like look i mean you can you
can accept the reality of situation
that's what it is but i know what's
going on with you right like reid told
me what's inside of you like what you
have inside of your body is basically
the
the dna capsules of your family you want
to bring your people back you're trying
to find some universe out there
you're hitching a ride with a cabal more
or less destroying worlds along the way
but you're trying to find some place
that you can basically call home
and you can you can bring your family
back because you're hoping against hope
that not everything will end you're
hoping the cabal is successful and
staving off the destruction of the
multiverse or
you were hoping that we were which is
why you sided with us and if both of us
fail then you're gonna you're gonna hit
your horse to another group hoping
they're successful but you're going to
bounce from person from group to group
to group until you find one that can get
you what it is that you need but at the
end of the day you're putting off this
air that like you're a person who's been
changed by the wheel of death the wheel
of destruction and you server boom all
the great destroyer the person who
started the incursions and you
you you champion all this stuff but in
reality you're just a sad little girl
who wants to bring your family back and
deep down you know
that that's never going to happen and
that's when we kind of get an
explanation of what's going on here
because then she in turn
counters tony stark and says and who are
you but what the wheel has made you
this entire cycle this is the death of
universes destroying worlds who are you
besides what this has done to you right
we are all a product of the circumstance
that we're in
like do not forget i remember where you
were when you fell right and what we end
up finding out is that after the events
of superior iron man that tony stark
tracked down the cabal he tracked down
thanos he tracked them all down and
tried to destroy them and was ultimately
defeated and then put here right it all
happened off panel and this is the only
real explanation that we get right as
far as i'm aware it's not in any kind of
a one-shot comic or anything it's not
like you know the last battle of
superior iron man
doesn't really exist out there not that
i'm aware of this is kind of the only
explanation that you get but in the end
she says like they put you in this cage
you know and and the the reality of this
is i will find what i'm searching for
but you will not
because you have failed to understand
that there are things out there more
important than you and so in that moment
we basically end up finding out that the
two individuals who had snuck in
were black widow and spider girl and
they were kind of watching this whole
conversation between
black swan and tony stark albeit they
were essentially invisible and so once
she leaves then they make their presence
known and this is the true
fall of iron man right this is the true
fall of tony stark because once they
approach him
and he's kind of like man i'm so glad to
see you guys you know that it's it's
like man i'm i'm glad to see friends the
response is i'm cut
like we're kind of amazed that you still
believe you have friends because
remember it was the great deception of
tony stark right like it was the great
lie of tony stark that led to the rift
in the avengers keep in mind
the way this played out is that black
panther was the first one to encounter
an incursion and knowing that it was a
planetary a planetary threat because it
literally led to black swan destroying
an entire world the black panther
captured black swan and then called
together the illuminati which includes
steve rogers to the point including
captain america and once the infinity
gauntlet was destroyed in their first
attempt to stop doing stop an incursion
which they successfully did but it
destroyed the the infinity gauntlet in
the in the first place then it turned
into
okay then how do we stop this and that's
when the illuminati started having the
conversation about destroying worlds and
then captain america said no i don't
want to destroy worlds right like i
don't want to blow worlds up i'm not
okay with wiping out billions of
innocent people just to save our own
world with the smartest men in the room
there has to be
a better a better choice right this is
low-hanging fruit it's the easiest
option and so in response to that
steve rogers mind was white by doctor
strange right like tony stark was the
one who told him to like that was the
backup plan that tony stark created
was if captain america is not on board
which he's most likely not going to be
then doctor strange
wipe his mind we'll send him back out
into the world and he'll be none the
wiser in order to distract captain
america from ever really you know kind
of having
any real measure of free time in his own
mind which is to say to keep him from
going on a path where he could recall
everything that was going on tony stark
came up with the idea of the avengers
machine well hey captain america i've
got a great idea well what's that what's
that tony uh we should create avengers
across the world
isn't that an awesome project you should
work on this right like it's your dream
come true and so in in that captain
america only focused on that it was yet
another ruse by tony stark in the
background he and the illuminati were
doing whatever they had to do which
included destroying worlds none of the
avengers knew what was going on
nobody knew what was happening except
for tony stark and the illuminati this
led to the events of original sin which
saw all the secrets of basically
everybody out there
being spilled out to the world and
that's when captain america recalled
everything the illuminati were doing and
the fact that they wiped his mind and
that's when he cornered tony stark and
then once you know the whole 50 000
years in the future and all that kind of
stuff ended and then captain america
came back to the present that's when he
assembled the avengers told him
everything that was going on
and that's what led to this rift is
because once captain america told all
the superheroes and even terex the team
were going into the world and just
telling everybody in the world what was
happening
once all the superheroes learned what
was going on with the collapse of the
multiverse that the illuminati were
secretly destroying worlds different
things like that then there was a
massive split
one section of the group agreed with
with the illuminati right they sided
with them and said they're doing what
needs to be done in order to save our
world
sorry about everybody else's luck the
other group sided with captain america
and saying
steve rogers is right i mean it's kind
of like a civil war all over again but
they're like steve rogers is right right
they're the smartest men in the world
surely they could come up with a better
option than just wiping out worlds the
reality was that there was no other
option there was no other way that's
what black widow is talking about when
she's like this amazing people
amazing that you believe that you still
have friends because despite the rift
that was created
just because they sided with the
illuminati does not mean they agreed
with tony stark and that's the big
difference is that tony's they they all
believe tony lied to them it's just
the final lie right it's the fight it's
the last time that they're tired of
dealing with all his
you know pardon my french they were
tired of all these instances when tony
saw himself as a cut above
everybody else that's what they were
exhausted with and that's what's being
explained here because when they in turn
say the only way we can let you out of
here the only way we can help you is if
you agree with the fact that you need
help tony stark
stands resolved and says no i don't need
help i'm the only one that can save
anybody here right if
it wasn't for me we would have been dead
a long time ago if you if you pray to a
god
pray to him that's fine but let me out
of this place because if i'm not out
there
all of you are going to die right it's
tony stark's arrogance in the most
extreme way
but it's also true and we'll find out
that like not having tony stark out
there
really actually does speed up the death
of everything right like it really
it really is worse for the superhero
community now at this point we switch
over to a character named pod now we
talked about pod in a previous video but
the cool thing about this is it
basically kind of clarifies things a
little bit more and what we ended up
finding out was that pod was just kind
of like this organism right this
cybernetic kind of robot looking thing
that really looked a lot like the fury
from the old magim jasper's captain
britain comics but basically pod was
just like this kind of you know device
or at least
this robot that was basically escaped
from advanced idea mechanics and then
fought the avengers laid waste to the
avengers and then kind of took off and
and then was grabbed by advanced idea
mechanics again and then sent out into
the space between universes right kind
of this more or less holding cell there
was nothing there so it would just kind
of sit there and wait
we kind of get into this little bit of
an explanation where we get an origin
and what we end up finding out here is
that pod was engineered
by x mihilo on mars right where ex
nihilo wanted to
basically evolve the earth and turn the
earth into a living life form that what
this did is it led to the idea that ex
nihilo
from his stance the earth needed a
defense system right it needed some way
to defend itself now this was
done absent ex nihilo's knowledge of
like the star brand that the star brand
basically initiates
whenever a a planet reaches a point
where its people are ready to move into
the next stage of their evolution and
individuals as a whole which is to say
the entirety of that planet's life forms
are able to like
move beyond their world and start
exploring other things right because
what that would do is it would leave
their world vulnerable right when
they're ready to move on to their next
state of evolution and so in that time
the white event would be initiated
that would create a night mask it would
create a star brand these different
characters but remember the white event
and the creation of the star brand was
done prematurely so it was never really
supposed to happen but x nihilo it's his
own agenda he's just doing his own thing
out there and so that's where pod came
from pod was basically a cybernetic
organism that was sent to earth by ex
nihilo to be its defense system and then
bonded to a little girl from norway and
when that happened it basically led to
them just kind of becoming a singular
entity the issue with this was that when
this bomb happened or when this arrival
happened and when this girl was bonded
to the suit more or less that advanced
idea mechanics popped up realizing that
it could be used as a weapon
took it and that's what led to the
conflict between the avengers and pod
and so what it does is it kind of
switches over to the current moment and
one of the things we talked about in the
previous videos
is that we have different plans going on
right so for those of you guys who kind
of feel a little bit lost with
everything that's kind of happening
at the current moment the way it plays
out like this and it's actually really
cool because hickman explains it through
robert decosta right because he brings
on
some new people who haven't really been
a part of everything decosta was doing
and what he basically says
is that the incursions of course as we
explained a minute ago began
black panther was the first one to
realize it was happening he recalled the
illuminati they started finding a way to
try to try to stop the incursions
ultimately coming to the realization
they had to destroy worlds to do it they
went off and did their own thing the
avengers were focusing on their own
thing
original sin happens the avengers become
aware of the incursions and they become
aware of the fact that the illuminati
are most likely destroying worlds
captain america
takes control of shield and in turn he
takes those friendly avenger forces
which is to say
the people two are the people that are
to his side and he says the illuminati
are public enemy number one our job is
to track them down catch them arrest
them and then put them on trial and then
while we have them try to find some way
to stop the incursions while that was
all going on
robert decosta purchased advanced idea
mechanics because advanced idea
mechanics had also come to the real
to the realization that the incursions
were happening that the the multiverse
was collapsing but where advanced idea
mechanics was doing it or at least
doing their research for the purpose of
trying to like find some way to use it
for their own ends robert decosta
bought advanced idea mechanics and then
he started using their technology as a
means to explore the incursions to find
out what the point was
that led to the creation of the
multiversal avengers team thor hyperion
extrahilo abyss a few other characters
and their job is to go out into the
multiverse and define the cause of the
incursions and then to destroy it right
to bring it to an end
and so one of the things that ends up
happening or at least one of the
revelations that we get here is that
robert de costa has spies on both sides
he's got spies in captain america's camp
and he's got spies in uh in the
illuminati the spy in the illuminati
comes by way of beast and it was
actually beast
who approached robert decosta because
remember robert de casa is a mutant and
he was associated with the x-men for a
little while even though he's not really
associated with them now and so because
of that as sunspot he's always kind of
been an
intriguing character but when beast
approached cyclops and said hey look
like i need to talk with somebody like
robert decosta right i need to talk to
him because of the fact that i'm aware
of what he's doing forming his own
new avengers group basically advanced
idea mechanics you know that avengers
team and so on like
i need to get with him and so you ended
up having cyclops who still
facilitated the meeting between the two
and basically one of the things the
cyclops reveals
is that the x-men have also been trying
to find a way to stop the incursions but
while their efforts are not nearly as
complex or in-depth as anybody else's
they are in possession of a phoenix egg
basically meaning that if they activated
the phoenix force would be reborn again
that's a pretty big thing
the the x-men are looking to recreate
the phoenix in order to stop the
incursion so again
all hands are on deck here everybody's
everybody's aware of it everybody's
trying to find a way to end it but
basically once beast has a conversation
with decosta beast is kind of looking
for absolution right he's not happy with
the things that the illuminati have done
they fly in the face of everything that
he believes he understands
that that it's it's the role they play
but it's it's one of the things where he
doesn't want to confuse
you know expediency with desire which is
to say needs and wants
they need to find a way to stop the
incursions even if it means destroying
worlds but they don't want to and what
the illuminati are mostly focusing on
right now is stopping the cabal
right trying to find a way to end the
cabal because it's one thing to try to
find a way to keep these worlds safe
maybe they can come across another
alternate reality where they found a way
to
to stave off the incursions by basically
taking their planet out of phase
basically making it intangible so that
the earth passed through each other
instead of one hitting the other and
destroying you know both realities
that's something the illuminati could
figure out right they could they could
find a scientific solution to this but
the cabal are just wiping stuff out
right they're just showing up showing up
on worlds obliterating the world
superheroes if there are any and then
blowing the planet up and leaving right
that's
that's all the cabal are doing and so
with beast now on the side of robert
decosta
this basically comes to the realization
that when you have black widow and you
have uh jessica drew spider-woman that
they
are on the side of captain america but
basically they're spies for robert
acosta as well right like they're
working for him and it's the smartest
move to make for all the arrogance that
robert decosta has he's
wildly intelligent and putting spies in
on both sides is actually something he
learned from the first civil war right
so it's what captain america and what
iron man did iron man had spies on
captain america's side captain america
had spies on iron man's side it's
the way they were able to keep track on
the other team but basically the idea
here
is that what robert decosta is doing is
amassing a kind of force right he's
amassing a way to stave off the
incursions or a way to get out get off
of earth right he's the only one that's
really thinking rationally
everybody out there is thinking about
how to stop the incursions he's the only
one who's really taking valeria's advice
despite the fact that she never gave it
to him and he doesn't know what her
advice is
which is to find a way to not lose and
the only way to not lose
is to leave the earth that's the only
way to do it and then find a new world
to settle down in and then destroy the
world right like destroy the earth that
way the universe continues living on
despite the fact that there would be a
lot of dead people
but it's it's it's literally just
utilitarianism saving as many people as
you possibly can
but one of the things that that that he
basically did one of the measures he
took
was to send shane chi to one of the
origin bomb sites right those are the
sites uh
the places where ex nihilo was trying to
evolve the earth and then like shot
these different bombs to earth that
basically had different purposes one was
to give the earth
sentience right to give it like a living
intelligence another one was to give it
like a defense system in the form of pod
this one was self-replication and so the
greatest martial arts master in the
entirety of the marvel universe
the single greatest fighter in the
entirety of the marvel universe there's
now an
army of him and what that would do is
allow him to face off against any number
of threats or to defeat any number of
people
who end up showing up there but to also
give them the ability to vacate the
world if it's necessary
sheer numbers right the ability to
multiply on a massive scale and so with
that being said guys i was going to
continue on with the next section
basically focusing on the black priest
but i feel like this is a lot to take in
already
right like i feel like this is kind of a
lot to go through already a lot has
happened
so yeah we're gonna go ahead and in this
video in the next video we do we'll
focus on the black priests we'll focus
on
basically the multiversal avengers and
all that kind of cool stuff and
essentially everything that comes next
right everything that sort of jumps next
into this this massive event especially
with the idea that like you can't win
right just the you can't win story arc
which is amazing it's it's absolutely
amazing but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you